You don't hear much praise for China
in the United States these days.
To be fair, China doesn't say
great things about the US either.
(Laughter)
The two big nations are stuck
in a geopolitical deadlock
that is bad for progress
to fight climate change.
I'm a China sustainability policy analyst
and I have witnessed
a clean energy revolution there
that could mean big things
for the rest of the world.
But it's become clear to me
that if the US continues
to see China as a threat,
the desired transition
will never happen at the faster pace
and the larger scale as expected.
We urgently need to pivot
from the currently dismal relations
and reset a constructive
rather than destructive foundation
for a global clean energy revolution.
(Applause)
Let's take a look
at the clean energy manufacturing,
because this seems to be
where the tension lies today.
Some US commentators said,
"The best chance was 10 years ago.
The second best chance is now."
The best chance was China's drive
to invest aggressively and ambitiously
in clean technologies
with the China Make 2025 campaign.
The outcome is massive deployment
of clean energy solutions
that established China
as a global leader in this landscape.
The US Inflation Reduction Act in 2022,
a climate law that pushes for investments
in domestic clean energy production,
represents the second best chance.
The IEA executive director Fatih
vividly called this dynamic
“the beginning of a new age
of clean energy manufacturing.”
A decade apart, China and the US
stand at a different position
along the global value chain.
While China is already
in the second decade of transition,
the US is just starting to take off.
The recent data shows China provided
77 percent of global batteries last year
and it is right on track
to lead all nations
in manufacturing
clean energy products by 2030.
China's investment
has also put it as a global leader,
leading exporter of those technologies:
solar, wind, batteries,
you name it.
My professional experience also tells me
that the US can learn a great deal
from China's steadfast dedication
to push forward the clean energy
transition in some key ways.
Firstly, China is re-energizing
the world's largest energy system
with renewables
and smart grid infrastructure.
And the US can adapt this
with a much shorter learning curve
and reduced costs.
The first half of this year
saw 34 percent of China’s electricity
generated from non-fossil fuels,
right on track to deliver
39 percent by 2025,
as has been planned,
and aiming for 80 percent by 2035.
Between now and 2035,
China's national endeavors are focused
on rapid expansion of installations
and also consumption of clean energy
in all sectors you could imagine.
In the meantime,
it's also dedicated to enhancing
grid transmission and distribution systems
to accommodate this growth of renewables.
US and China operate power systems
in two different regulatory contexts,
but share the logic and also technicality
when designing and building
a clean, smart, net-zero
carbon emissions grid system.
China is also becoming a real daredevil
in pioneering the development of 5G
and AI-enabled power systems
and deploying the
ultra-high-voltage grid systems
supplemented by
vehicle-to-grid technologies
in order to accommodate the rise of EVs.
China's experience can provide
an invaluable reference or insight
for the US to decarbonize
your own power system.
Secondly, China is leading
a global campaign
to increase solar usage.
The social, economic and environmental
model deployed in China
can help the US to address
climate injustice challenges domestically.
Solar energy is becoming
the least-cost option
for new electricity generation
in most parts of the world today.
The IEA forecasts an average annual
solar generation growth
of 25 percent between 2022 and 2030,
which is about 10 times
of the current total global installations,
in order to achieve net-zero
carbon emissions by mid-century.
Or to put it another way,
this is one kilowatt
solar installation per person by 2030.
That number stands today
at one-tenth kilowatt globally.
China is on its way
to achieve two-fifths kilowatt
by the end of this year.
To bridge the gap, a group of leading
Chinese universities and institutions
launched a China campaign
advocating one kilowatt
solar installation per person by 2030.
The strategy is -- and also
turning that into a global campaign,
called Solar Lights the Planet.
The strategy is to really use
solar installation
as the intervention point
to explore how rural
energy transition in China
can benefit other
UN sustainability targets.
On one side, it's cost-effective.
One kilowatt solar installation
requires five square meters of space
and a 500-dollar
upfront investment to install.
When completed,
it generates green electricity
while avoiding carbon emissions.
And on the other side,
it also demonstrates that co-benefits
can be created and maximized.
Rapid rural energy transition
can bring new investment
and also create green power-enabled
growth opportunities,
for instance, food, agriculture,
fishery, energy services,
tourism and other industries.
China's experience definitely
can be very valuable for the US
to think about the solutions
to address climate injustice.
Solar Lights The Planet is the ambition.
It also offers colleagues
in the United States
to work with peers from China
and other parts of the world
to really tackle
the climate injustice challenge.
Thirdly, China is mainstreaming
a circular economy
and transforming its supply chains.
Joining forces, China,
the US, together with the EU,
can literally reset the global
supply chain solidly on sustainability.
China is a global
manufacturing powerhouse.
Its demand for raw materials
and critical metals
is growing exponentially.
As we all know, the planet
cannot possibly afford
the ecological destruction from quadruple,
and in some cases even six times
the current import of critical metals
to match the planned energy transition.
A circular economy offers a remedy
to decouple the growth from resource use.
China is also well positioned
to reset its supply chains
with circularity at the core.
Today, China recycles more than
95 percent of nickel and lithium.
Business communities
have a big role to play,
providing solutions or answers
to what hurdles to remove,
what innovative solutions to deploy,
what business models actually to promote,
and very importantly,
how to consolidate a global partnership
to work together to shape our sustainable
and circular global supply chain.
Which is why a group of Chinese
organizations are working together,
kicking off a China
Circularity 100 initiative,
aiming by 2030 to really find the pathways
to close the loop in recycling
for critical metals
and also for the energy sector.
It's targeting at least 100 companies
to work together
to find the alternative pathways.
China's practice can become
a very important reference
for the United States
to make investment decisions
to embrace circularity now.
So how do we jump-start
a new US-China partnership?
Well, the two governments ...
should start with a revised narrative,
one that is with good intention,
as well as with collaborative spirit.
In the meantime, the two nations
need to assure the rest of the world
that they are really seriously
and sincerely working together
to find their alternative
and to rebuild partnership.
One thing to keep in mind:
the climate change doesn't care
about our ideological divide.
Rather, it demands for collective actions
that deliver outcomes.
Cornering China
as a national security threat
seems to claim that the US,
rather than China,
is the legitimate and trustworthy
global leader in this transition.
And yet, as the world's largest
developed economy,
the US doesn't meet the bar
of what's expected of a global leader.
Along the line, it doesn't provide
the rest of the world
with sufficient, accessible
and affordable clean energy solutions,
nor does it provide, deliver
its financial commitments
to other developing countries
under the Paris Agreement.
And China undoubtedly
has to go a long way too
in rethinking its strategy and behavior
in dealing with the US.
It needs to make extra efforts
to convince the world
that it's not a threat,
but rather a trusted partner,
willing and capable to work with the US
to shift towards
a collaborative partnership.
Let me leave this stage
with some sort of cautious optimism.
My heart feels enlightened
when media in our two countries
start to tell different US-China stories.
Treasury Secretary Yellen's
China trip last week
went viral in Chinese social media.
The rainbow welcoming
her landing in Beijing Airport
represents some hope
and also a new beginning
of bilateral relations.
And her love for the wild mushroom
soup from Yunnan province --
(Laughter)
literally gives me this kind of a warm
and also sweet human touch.
And I have a message
to climate envoy John Kerry,
who is coming to China later this month.
You know, the two governments
have already declared quite a number
of joint commitments
and collective actions
to fight climate change.
What's urgently needed now
is a shared vision, mission, aspiration,
wisdom and very importantly,
a compass to guide everyone back on track,
to take collective actions
and deliver the due results.
It seems to me that's
the must-have precondition for us all
in order to keep
a sustainable future within reach.
Thank you.
(Applause)